can as a tenured professor in your
mid-40s what made you think that you
could change careers well this is
America and you can do whatever you want
to do it's one of the great things about
this country and I was what I was doing
was very related to a career I'm in now
it was developing stories developing
writers and of course teaching a number
of things that I no longer teach like
classical literature and Italian
literature and I do miss I do miss that
part but it was basically an extension
of what I've been doing all of my life
which is developing stories analyzing
stories publishing stories helping
people publish stories and now getting
stories produced into movies so it's all
united by storytelling I had no idea
which world was sort of the bigger world
of ideas the world of academia that I
had been in for 17 years or the world I
went into and I discovered that the
world I went into was really the world
of ideas because it's a world in which
people are tracking ideas across
continents to find out who owns the
rights to a story they're you know they
they pay lots of money to acquire the
story they use least they used to pay a
lots of money and they spend millions of
dollars to turn the story into a movie
and they're fiercely competitive about
the world of ideas it's the motion
picture business is the jungle of ideas
and it's survival of the the best idea
and the best business people I always
say it's it's called show business for a
reason it's not just about show it's
about the business of how stories get
developed into movies that the whole
world can see I'm hoping we can go back
to maybe right before you made this
transition into wanting to be in film
was there something that happened was
there just a time in your life in your
mid 40s where you just felt like you
know what
I want a new challenge you know that's a
good question because that's my I
reflected on it all my life
since then and it was actually provoked
by my receiving tenure I actually
belonged to a untenured faculty
committee against tenure and one day
when I was a Fulbright professor in
Bologna Italy I got a telegram from the
Dean of the faculty at Occidental
College telling me that I'd received
tenure in my absence and my reaction to
it was not very understandable to my
friends and colleagues I I became deeply
depressed for about a year and it took
me a long time to figure out why it was
depressed and it was because I had
really never asked to be in this golden
cage where nothing can happen to you it
was like the most secure place you could
be and I realized at the time that my
father's chief value in life was
security he was a child with a
depression and security was all
important to him and I had to admit to
myself that it wasn't that important to
me I never worried about being secure I
published lots of things and I was in
demand as a speaker and just never had
to worry about it
and what my value was was freedom and I
didn't feel freedom when under a
structure where you had to behave a
certain way and you had to know a year
in advance that on the week of October
12th you'd be teaching book eight of the
Iliad and that it was wonderful to be
teaching the Elliot but to have two to
know that a year in advance you're gonna
be somewhere I now live in a world where
I don't know where and get a B tomorrow
literally and and it's complete opposite
it's the world it's a free world and of
course I realized as I got older that
freedom is as much an illusion as
security both of them are illusions but
it was my illusion security was not my
illusion and so I've lived with complete
insecurity but with the freedom to
express myself creatively in every
possible way which is what the film
business allows me to do and so that was
very exciting to me do you ever tell
people that that if they're looking to
be in a creative pursuit whether it's
being an author or screenwriter actor
that security is something that will
probably not be part of what they'll
encounter and you okay with that
absolutely I mean this is not a career
to wish on anyone you have to have a
burning desire to do it and you have to
be willing to sacrifice anything to do
it and to persist despite every setback
and I can tell you that this is a
business in which a career in which this
never gets easier I don't care how many
movies you've done the next one is going
to be the biggest challenge you've ever
faced the world changes all the time
it's been changing ever since I've been
in it which is around 30 years now and
it never gets any easier and it never
gets any more secure and you know even
if you had windfalls and lots of money
you would put it into your next you know
your next project because people in this
business believe in what they're doing
that's their most important common
belief you can see it at the Academy
Awards you you hear the stories as they
receive rewards that they never thought
they'd get or have been waiting for a
lifetime for they all have one thing in
common the ability to sacrifice what
everyone else considers the most
important things in order to achieve the
dream of getting the story told to the
whole world and that's Nestle the great
thing about the career there's no limits
to it it's infinitely challenging it's
constantly challenging there surprises
every day and it's completely
unpredictable I'm almost thinking of a
sales position like door to door where
you have to just suit up and and go on
your
you're in work your farm and it sounds
like with this industry it's it's an
everyday sort of you have to be that
person sort of drumming up leads and
things like that yeah it's a completely
self-starting business you hear
repeatedly from actors and from writers
and from everyone that being represented
by a agency does not really help because
everyone said I always get my I've
always gotten my best jobs by myself and
I hear that from musicians and from
every member of this business that they
get their own work and and suiting up is
every morning is putting on your brain
and telling it that it's got to be happy
and go out there and it doesn't matter
how bad things are in reality you have
to put on a happy face and I have gone
to many meetings that I absolutely did
not feel like going to because something
had just happened that was a setback and
I just thought I want to stay home lick
my wounds but I go to the meeting and it
always turns out that those meetings are
the best meetings that you go to and
when you walk out you think thank God I
went I mean what would have happened if
I hadn't gone and that that is suiting
up that is definitely a kind of a
nightly encounter to put on your armor
and go out there and you're working with
people who are doing the same thing and
that's part of the exhilaration of it is
that you know that the person sitting
across from you may have had worse
things happen to him in the last 24
hours
but he's still there on the job and
putting on a happy face and getting it
done it's it's very deceptive and
seductive when people come here for the
first time especially clients of mine I
I warned them that they will be
experiencing what's called the
development dance where everyone will be
extremely nice to them and extremely
positive and then they'll never hear
from them again and that's because
people are doing their job and their
their job is to find out what this
person has to offer the world and if
it's extremely exciting which is rare
very rare then you'll hear from them but
most the time it's not extremely
exciting and exciting enough and/or it
doesn't fit the agenda of the of this
person's company at the moment they have
something too much like it in
development or they have a boss who does
not want to do that particular kind of
thing etc but their job is to be the
best audience possible for any story
that comes along it could be a dramatic
story that people would you know that
would attract audiences and so they'll
they'll be happy and then in the meeting
and then at the end of the meeting you
know behind the back of the person who
came to the meeting they'll make a
decision about whether to pursue it or
not and that's what you're up against so
you are like a door-to-door salesman I
always say there's a great black Florida
in the sky that has every know you'll
ever receive in your life written on it
and finally a yes at the end of the nose
and the only catch is you can't see it
so what do you do you you go through the
nose as fast as you can that's the only
way to deal with that blackboard and
that's what successful people do in the
business they just keep getting those
nose until somebody says yes what key
steps did you take to go from being a
tenured professor most people would do
many things that probably aren't good to
be in those shoes to a movie producer
what I'm sure first of all you had to
deal with social pressure people
probably trying to talk you out of it
maybe not what steps did you take well
in retrospect you can always make it
look more you know planned and logical
then that it was at the time but I
basically I ran into a very inspiring
man whose name was Norman Cousins who
was the editor of Saturday Review world
in those days and he came to speak in a
class of mine at Occidental College and
it turned out we shared a motto that no
one else in the world had ever
and the motto was a was a single
sentence by the philosophy anis
philosopher or take a guess a that said
I think the only immoral thing is for a
beam not to use every instant of its
existence with the utmost intensity and
I had never heard anyone else quote that
but after after his talk in my class I
asked him to come to my office and
showed him that it was framed above my
desk and so needless to say we bonded
and long story short I asked him you
know what I should do when I grow up
which I asked male authority figures all
my life basically and he he told me
after we got to know each other that I
should consider the entertainment
business because it was much broader
than the academic world and people can
basically do whatever you know it
anything creative you're encouraged to
do basically you could find your own way
there are no rules and schedules and all
of those kinds of things that we find in
academia and I love academic you know
the world and the ideas that are
exchanged and all of that but it was
restricting and it was you know for me
suffocating which is a word that his
means a lot to me personally it's my
most ancient nightmares being suffocated
and I've never been suffocated and you
know in the entertainment world I'd been
terrified a lot but not suffocated and
so he encouraged me and I thought well I
don't know anything about the
entertainment world other than movies
that I've seen that's it and he showed
me a passage from a book by William
Goldman that I hope everyone know is
called adventures in the screen trade
and the passage was that the only
important rule in Hollywood is that
nobody knows anything and I thought well
that's that's good means it's a level
playing field so I set out to learn as
much as I could and I realized that I
wasn't 18 years old in the mailroom that
William Morris and I wasn't you know
infinitely wealthy and I didn't have
relatives in the film business those are
like the three main ways to get into the
business normally so I thought I just
have to be smarter so I started writing
reading contracts I remember a producer
I'll never forget I asked him if I could
read a distribution contract and he said
yeah I can let you read it but I can't
let you take it out of my office you can
go up the other room and have a
cappuccino and but you know do that so I
read it and I came back an hour later
and I said I'm confused about some
things I read here can I ask you a
couple questions and he said sure and he
I said this paragraph number 48 in the
fine print section at the end says that
accounting terms used in this agreement
shall be redefined by the twentieth
century-fox accounting department at
such time if any that litigation is
entered into among the parties I said
what does that mean and he said that
it's not in there I go yes it is let me
show you how I showed it to him and he
said I can't believe that that's still
in there my my attorney should have
crossed that out he had just signed the
agreement and I said well they didn't so
I started learning that's how I started
learning by reading contracts because I
think whatever kind of thing you're
trying to do if it's successful ends up
with being a bunch of contracts so you
might as well start backwards with the
contracts and long story short while I
was preparing myself that way over a
six-month period I I came up with an
idea that I sold basically on a wing and
a prayer not knowing how to do it but it
ended up being within the next 12 months
16 movies that I was completely in
charge of and raised half the money from
Warner Brothers and half the money from
from a company in Canada went up to
Montreal and shot them all back-to-back
meaning one movie ended on Friday and
the next one be
on Monday and it was a series of
romantic comedies and it came out of my
teaching romantic literature and also
teaching publishing because a publisher
was talking in one up in my publishing
class the visiting publisher was talking
to my class and he was telling me he was
telling us what goes on the cover of a
romance novel and I realized as he
listed the things that were on the cover
that he was basically reciting the rules
of courtly love that I was teaching in
another class that were written in the
12th century by andreas capital honesty
the Chaplin of Marie de France and and I
thought so maybe romance novels that
everyone makes fun of are just an
extension of these ancient courtly
stories these love stories and I came up
with the idea of doing a series of
movies that imitated these love stories
and were marketing friendly because they
all had colors so you could have put all
the DVDs on the you know on the shelf
and they would form a rainbow said they
were all called things like The Rose
cafe sunset court indigo autumn etc and
we did 16 of them and by that time I was
I was fully in the business because I
was in charge of production as a
creative production and within three
movies my assistant I were you know we
knew we were doing whereas we did not
have any idea what we were doing before
the first movie started shooting and
then I came back to Los Angeles and
became a literary manager because I
didn't have resources to option
properties but as a literary manager you
can produce properties by managing the
property and that's what got me going
and
ever since then so was that was how the
transition occurred and it was just
because I thought of an idea and I
didn't know better if I known now what
you know what if I'd known then what I
know now I would never have sold it the
way I sold it I simply went out with the
concept and convinced several Studios to
look at it seriously and none of them
had looked at a script or anything like
that and one of them Warner Brothers
wanted to see a script and I wouldn't
show it to them until they'd signed an
agreement and they ended up signing an
agreement in three days and then I
showed them they manufactured the
scripts over the weekend by putting out
a call to the romance novel community
and getting back you know ideas for the
script and so on so it was a fluke and
one of the hardest things about being in
the business when you're been in it for
a while is the there grows up this huge
accumulation of experience that you have
that makes you know that you shouldn't
just pick up the phone and call the head
of a studio and and I have to overcome
that I just reached out to the head of a
studio this morning but every time I do
it it's like having a 500-pound weight
in your hand to pick up the phone
because you know that's wrong but
somebody like me back then I didn't know
was wrong so I you know it was light
there's the light motion to pick up the
phone and call call somebody and so
whenever I get a new partner who's not
involved I always say don't be afraid to
tell me your craziest ideas because this
is a world in which crazy ideas work and
you know it's it's the traditional ideas
that have a harder time working so it is
a completely wild and entrepreneurial
frontier it's probably the last frontier
of American culture though the movie
business and it's been changing ever
since I've been in it it constantly
changes from a world in which
videocassettes dominated and you could
find them everywhere and to a world in
which we're down streaming from Netflix
and Hulu and so on and
the delivery methods have always changed
and what doesn't change and this is the
encouraging thing for writers is that
the need for stories has only gotten
greater and greater with the
proliferation of hundreds of channels
they all have one thing in common they
need programming they need content and
writers are the ones who create the
content the intellectual property so
they should be hugely encouraged you
don't have to understand all the
distribution methods you just need to
know how to tell a story and and you're
in good shape just keep telling stories
how did you learn to tell a great story
you know I learned how to tell stories
on the porch in Louisiana when I was
growing up because I had I was growing
up in the country and born on a farm and
my uncles were all you know farmers and
storytellers and we sat on the front
porch and told stories and every
conversation started as a conversation
but quickly went into a story even a
trip to town was a story everything was
the story and I noticed a chorus quickly
that some people could tell them and
some people couldn't I mean a lot of
stories down there were jokes and you
know what uncle I had the minute he
started talking everybody seemed to
leave the porch because he was the
dullest storyteller I have ever run into
in my life you know I loved him dearly
loved to go fishing with him but don't
let him get to telling the story because
it takes him forever to tell it and at
the end you can't even remember how it
began but the other uncle was
mesmerizing and you loved listening to
his stories and when he started telling
stories people started showing up on the
porch and I think that's really where I
learned where I realized that this was a
basic form of human communication that I
wasn't getting in Kansas City which was
much more businesslike and conversation
was for the sake of getting to the next
point in the day and down there it was a
it was a focus in itself you know
everyone looked forward to getting up at
4:30 and sitting on the porch for an
hour telling stories before the day
began and and and then reassembling at
7:00 and telling stories until everyone
conked out at the end of the day so
that's definitely where I got the start
in loving the power of stories I mean I
think that those stories changed
everyone's lives and you never forget a
story I mean you can you can forget your
your mathematical equation and you can
forget you know your chemistry but you
just don't forget a good story
and that's made me fall in love with it
from the very beginning and I you know
I've been very lucky because they spent
my whole life dealing with stories
that's all I deal with every day what
three things does a great story have to
have with three things hmm well it has
to be it has to have a hook that gets
people instantly involved in the story
and and that is a huge part of the story
itself and it's it's got to have a very
strong character in the story that you
care about and other than that it has to
have twists and turns that lead to a
surprise ending and like if I had to
just say three things I guess that's
what I would say the three things are
every every story needs that because a
story about nothing is not gonna hold
anyone's interest and and sometimes
writers when they begin their careers
think that they just if they just write
they can write about anything but the
truth is they need to write from their
heart about met things that matter to
everyone and if they do that you can
hardly go wrong because stories are
really not about words or word choice or
anything like that they're about
conveying the power of a character
facing a dilemma that you have no idea
how he or she will will resolve and when
you do that you've got everyone's
attention and with in ancient times they
there was a thing called the oral
tradition which I used to teach as a
professor of Homeric Greek the Iliad and
the Odyssey were a son you know at
campfires and everyone in the culture
knew the stories it's we're publishing a
book right now on Homeric song and how
it worked and how it held culture
together and my first book was about
those I call those stories the shield of
memory then it was because of those
stories that a person you had a deal
with himself in battle or when facing a
attacking
or when facing an angry wife you know or
when facing the pillagers trying to burn
down his village they he would instantly
think of the story of Heracles who did
this and that or the story of you know a
gia and who did this and that and that's
all they had they didn't have books you
know for learning it was all passed
along through the oral tradition and I
think stories have never failed to play
that role in human life when you think
about it you know what your story is
probably the most human response to any
encounter and it goes from the court of
law where the jury is trying to decide
which of the two stories do they believe
to a political campaign where the voters
are making that decision to a first date
where you're going do I believe his
story I just don't believe it I can't
buy his story that's that's the ultimate
human turned out you can't buy the story
and it goes through everything
advertising is conveying stories that
people will you know so that people will
want to buy the product this is how
humans operate on a daily basis so to me
it's absolutely amazing that an industry
has been created where people will pay
millions of dollars for stories and
where stories can basically conquer the
world and I believe unites the world I
mean look at all the work Weird Al doing
with China in the movie business I just
saw Lara Croft in Tomb Raider the new
version of it where the male lead is
Chinese and she is Western and clearly
as a producer I'm watching and going
this was a Chinese financed movie
because I understand how it works for
the market you know the Chinese hero
makes it perfect for the Chinese market
and he looks pretty good but she's the
real the real protagonist in the story
and she's great for the Western market
and she's a woman so it's all very
contemporary and etc so you see the
structure behind it is actually a
cultural change
because now the values of the West are
being inserted in the Chinese market
with the Chinese co-op cooperating with
them and as I believe China is becoming
more capitalistic all the time partly
through the influence of movies the
audience wants to see individual people
doing what they want to do in life and
going out there and kicking ass and not
being under the thumb of some you know
Emperor or despot so I think that this
is why the whole storytelling thing is
so exciting because it really is a
universal experience the question is
what stands in most people's way of
achieving their dreams it sounds simple
we can achieve dreams and you know
there's a million books on it but what
do you think is actually the block for
many people I know I've written a book
called quit your day job and leave the
life of your dreams based on my own
experience and that of others one of my
favorite stories that was on Joyce
brothers television show years ago with
a couple of other people and one of them
was that the man in his it was then in
his 80s and just had received his law
degree from the University of Chicago
and he was Ito he told her that he was
standing in line for registration four
years earlier and one of the young
people and lying behind him said sir are
you sure you're in the right line and he
said and I turned around and I said what
line should I be in and I thought that
is America that's the essence of America
you you are in whatever line you want to
be in in this country and he fearlessly
walked up and stood in the line and got
his law degree at the age of 86 or
whatever he was and to me it what stands
in people's way is fear and they're
their friends inflicted on them so one
of the chapters in my book has to do
with distinguishing between friends and
friendly associates because when I left
the academic world I had a few friends
and I had lots of friendly associates I
learned the difference when I decided to
leave because I retained a few
friends but most everybody I did not
retain as friends because they thought I
was absolutely crazy
they either thought that in a kind of
benign way or they just thought I was I
mean they were they just were extremely
angry that I was leaving a tenured
position they thought that was
completely uncool and crazy and I can
also say that they were fearful about it
and I knew well I knew them well enough
to know that many of them were envious
wish they could do it but just wouldn't
do it because they're set in their ways
and that's one of the reasons I didn't
like tenure because it once you had
tenure you didn't have to publish
anymore you didn't have to do anything
anymore and of course if you're truly
motivated that's not going to stop you
and there were a few people who were
unstoppable but mostly they weren't
unstoppable and they just stopped and to
me that was a crime because I didn't
understand anything other than the merit
system as you know something that should
rule an academy of ideas you know so I
think what makes people afraid of being
out on the street you know it's an image
that that I've had you know in the first
10 years of getting into a new world
where I realized I wasn't gonna get a
check every two weeks regularly you know
you you have that image if you were
raised by depression your parents and
and you also have the other image of the
wolves at the door
I remember that one because I found a
quick way around it go to the door open
the door and if you don't see any wolves
at the door then there are no wolves at
the door but it is it is an image that
pops into your mind in the middle
tonight as as does the homeless image
and many other things but if you're
afraid of images then you shouldn't be
in the world of images I mean that's
what I do is I create images and develop
images and turn them into movies so how
can I let you know images that are in my
brain control my actions you have to
learn to overcome that and so I think
people have to clearly understand
selves and and decide on who to listen
to you know if you truly are a friend
and you love somebody you encourage them
to fulfill their dreams and I always did
that to my students I always felt like
you have a dream and you're afraid of
accomplishing it what if your dream is
the most important dream that ever came
along in the human race and you don't do
anything about it it was your dream and
you do nothing about it to me that's a
sacrilege you know you you had the dream
for a reason you know it's in your mind
for a reason either God put it there or
it was born in your mind from some other
source why aren't you going to do
something about it well because I'm
afraid that my father and mother would
be really upset and I go so this is a
hypothetical fear about something that
hasn't happened yet right yes then why
not just do it and deal with the
possibility that may never happen at all
and that's it's a matter of knowing
yourself I mean that's one of the things
I talk about first in the book I was
raised on Greek philosophy and what it
said over the Oracle of Delphi was know
thyself that that's was the most
important piece of knowledge that Plato
and Aristotle and Socrates taught and
knowing yourself means you know you're
gonna be haunted by this dream if you
don't do it I mean I've had a partner
who said once when her movie was in
trouble maybe this is one of those
dreams that should never have happened
and I know that is complete blasphemy
you know you say that now but later you
will see that that was that when there
was some other voice talking to you
other than your own voice because you
you made this thing happen and you know
you will be proud of it as she was and
that's I think the simply fears the
number one impediment to people going
for their dreams and it's fear you know
everyone knows the acronyms about fear
it's fear is about things that haven't
happened yet that may never happen just
like worry and we all do it we all have
fears we all have worries but overcoming
your fears is what
you know valiant people do it's what you
know people that you would like to be
like do so why not do it yourself
and and not have to live with the regret
which is the big monster equal to fear
that you live with if you are sitting on
that proverbial front porch and your
rocking chair thinking about the dreams
that you had and didn't do me to me
that's a terrible waste of life to have
that happen also stripping away
illusions and you talk about knowing
thyself and being comfortable enough to
know that if you have to stand by
yourself for a while because you've lost
the illusion of some of the friendships
or peer group that you thought was going
to be there with you if for whatever
reason socially they've gone the other
way knowing that that's okay as well
yeah I mean that's a very good point
because I think as you get older you
realize that you cannot govern your life
by what other people think and it's you
know I live on the 11th floor and I look
out over the millions of lights and in
Los Angeles and it's a great comfort to
think that there are you know a few
lights out there that love me you know
there are maybe fewer that hate me and
but there are millions that have no idea
that I exist
that's comfortable and it's sort of the
cosmic view of life when you think about
it you're you're just one little tiny
piece of a massive cobb cosmos that is
going about its massive mechanism with
on its own without any need for you to
consult with it and for you to be
worried about what you know some other
person somewhere else thinks about you
it's a complete waste of your energy in
every way your job is to do what your
dreams tell you to do and to do it with
all your might the way the cosmos does
and what other people are saying and
thinking and doing first of all because
most of them are not spending any time
thinking about you at all could care
less what you do or don't do most of
them are thinking only about themselves
so that's a natural condition and why
should you be any
prynt you know if you have a dream just
do it and you fear that the crazy
painter that it's been turning out
paintings in the garage down the street
and everyone thinks you're cracked
laughs but then they learned that you
sold one of your paintings for a million
dollars and now it's gonna be in the
Louvre you know suddenly they go I
always knew that that gal was a genius
you know she she really had talent from
the very beginning people change
instantly which shows how much value of
their opinion really has right and
that's why I just think it's you know
you've got to really listen to yourself
and and not listen to everybody else and
the few people you can tell your friends
because the ones that support you in
doing that are your true friends amen
yeah if the person who's not supporting
you is I've had several clients in my
career who whose spouses did not support
them and you know my advice is divorce
your spouse I'm sorry you know like I
take this seriously I do this is a
profession this is a vocation and if you
know someone close to you is telling you
don't do it it's selfish you need to get
somebody else close to you you know who
will encourage you because I'll let all
the monumental great things in life I
think are done by people who go for it
and who are not afraid of taking the
chance and who are there for it's
supported by a few true friends you know
or loved ones who tell them to do it
you know it's many examples from my own
life but when I decided to leave the
tenured position my daughter was a
junior at Columbia and one thing that
would be jeopardized would be her senior
year at Columbia and I brought her up to
Montreal where I was shooting movies and
we had a long talk about it you know off
set and she said Dan you absolutely have
to do this you have to do it don't worry
about that and of course that problem
got solved and didn't have being a
problem but it was a concern but she had
no concern for it and that's how I know
know who my true friends are and that's
how you would know too if you decide you
want to do so
listen carefully to what the people
around you say because when people are
telling you know they're expressing
their own fears and some of it may be
good-hearted they're afraid that the
things they fear may happen to you but
if you're willing to take the risk you
know don't let them influence you
because they're not taking the risk
you know I'm unless they depend on you
and then you have to figure that out and
I and I did certain things when I left
that career to make sure that those who
depended on me would not you know end up
being left without resources so I did
what I had to do to make sure that
happened and then once I did that I like
my conscience was clear and I was able
to embrace it fully with all the risks
that it entailed
and I you know no regrets even though
there were some very dark times and and
there always ups and downs in a business
like this one and you know career that
is bereft of security you know the other
side of that coin is that as much as
security as an illusion rejection is
also an illusion because you can take as
many chances as you want
you know I constantly hear people tell
me even on the phone this morning
you only get one shot that was a
distributor telling me we only get one
shot and I thought well okay maybe
that's true for you but I get as many
shots as I want to take and Hollywood is
you know personal doesn't exist
what is Hollywood right it's just a
concept but in reality the business that
I'm in all you have to do is tell
somebody I've got a great news story and
they are all ears immediately they don't
care that it's been ten years since you
talked to them you know you spend a few
seconds in chitchat and then they want
to hear the story so you can take as
many you know as many chances as you
want to take unless your own psychology
disallows that because it wants you to
get depressed and you know spend go into
a coma of unhappiness and take rejection
seriously etc I just don't have time
you know one of my essays is called the
waiting room and it's about what you do
while you're waiting for an answer on a
creative project
well you don't wait you do something
else you know you make another creative
project you get it going and by the you
know if you keep doing that every
project has its own clock you can't do
much to control that clock but you can
be doing another project and sooner or
later you have projects all around you
that are in various states of ripeness
and they will happen in their own time
and your biggest problem will be what if
two of them happened at the same time
and I always say don't worry about that
I mean that's the kind of problem you
want to have you don't want to have the
problem of nothing happening so no you
don't wait at all and I think a lot of
writers torture themselves because they
wait you know they sent off a manuscript
hypothetically into the snail mail no
one does that anymore of it they send it
off and then they wait for an answer why
would they wait for an answer that's
complete waste of time
instead you instantly work on something
else
and that way when something comes from
the first thing you're just surprised
and you're you deal with it meet it
immediately without wasting any kind of
psychological energy on it you just if
it's a rejection you take take it and
you move on and if it's a if it's
somebody offering you a deal then you
consider the deal but you don't writers
feel like they have to spend an
additional 90% of their time
fretting over they're all analyzing it
you know soul-searching over it and you
do that when you're younger and it's
fine to do some of it because you may
get a lot of creativity out of it but
once you've gone through it and tortured
yourself you know to your own
satisfaction you don't have to do that
all the time you can just go back to
work and Ray Bradbury used to say that
to writers get back to work it'll get
rid of all these moods you're having you
know and I always thought that's the
most brilliant advice work is the
solution what do you wish someone had
sat you down and said to you in the
beginning of embarking on the
tainment side of your don't waste your
time I wish somebody had told me don't
waste your time because I've wasted some
time in my life leave or not despite you
know what I've said about not wasting
time and not waiting and I think that's
maybe the only advice that I would have
liked to hear but you know they also try
to put you in a niche like I was
constantly told find your niche find
your niche and I found it a magazine
once called DreamWorks and it was about
the the relationship between dreams and
the arts and it was an interdisciplinary
journal with Ursula Le Guin and Joyce
Carol Oates and John foals and Carlos
Puentes on the advisory board and many
others I mean 20 people of equal stature
and it covered all the arts and I was
told by one publisher it was too general
you need to find a niche and then
another publisher accepted it and
publishing it for ten years and so
listening to the advice of telling
someone telling you to find a niche so
the reason I'm fumbling about the answer
to your question is I really never had
that that issue in my life of what it
would what I wish someone had told me I
kept finding people that I respected who
told me the exact right thing that I
needed to hear and and one person around
this whole issue said what's remarkable
about you is your diversity never give
up your diversity no matter what and
that piece of advice was the most
wholesome piece of advice I could have
received and it was from a person I
respected tremendously so I never really
had that question of what I would like
to hear because I did hear it and it
meant that I wasn't afraid to go into
feature films with with
the major studios in two independent
films or into television and I you know
produce movies and and projects and all
those places and categories because I
never let anyone stop me from being
diverse and I thought that was that I
needed that piece of advice when I can I
got it diversity is something that I've
always been in love with because I was
when I was in college I was in English
and classics kind of double major
because I couldn't decide you know which
one to go for and when I heard about
comparative literature my last year at
Georgetown I thought this is perfect
it's the study of different cultures and
it's about putting things together you
know so I've written crazy pieces like
comparing Wallace Stevens to Peter arc
and you know Dante with Joyce and so on
and that's what I just think is the most
interesting thing is when you juxtapose
two things or three things rather than
focusing on one thing and that's one of
the things the academic world annoyed me
about sometimes until I discovered
comparative literature and took that
degree at Yale and and then ended up
teaching that and I think that the rest
of my life has been an extension of do
it working in more than one discipline I
mean in addition to movies I'm very
involved in books I've just finished
another book of my own and I've a
published books because four years ago I
realized that I was having a hard time
after published after selling books to
New York for 20 years or more and having
nearly 20 New York Times bestsellers I
realized that because of all the
conglomeration that was going on among
the publishers purchased by large
corporations around the world there was
no longer much chance for a young new
voice to be published what they're
looking for is established brands and
you know the old joke that Stephen
you can publish you know the phone book
with his name on it and that's that's
just the way it is in this you know huge
country where marketing and branding is
what it's all about to get the attention
of this 300 million audience so I came
up with the idea and what was happening
to me is because I didn't couldn't
publish things as easily as I could
before I published 250 books
I mean sold them to publishers and I
could take those books to Hollywood and
sell them to Hollywood so I no longer
had books to take to Hollywood so I
decided to start my own imprint story
emergent books which I did and that was
you know five years ago and we've
published over 200 books now and I now
take them to Hollywood and set them up
as series or set them up as movies and
no one seems to mind that they're not
Random House books they don't even look
at the publisher basically they listen
to me pitched the story at lunch and
then they take the book home and read it
and so I've always been involved in you
know it's sort of like comparative
situation because I've got New York
publishing and Hollywood and I've used
them back and forth against each other
one time because Hollywood has this huge
respect for books and New York has this
of movies primarily because of the
marketing money associated with movies
that they can then write along with when
they reached the book so I'm hoping to
have a big auction coming up soon on a
movie that's appearing this summer after
22 years called the Meg from Warner
Brothers and we sold it 22 years ago
that's how long it's been we developed
it through one of my companies and then
sold it to the publisher and then we
sold it to the studio and it's been 22
years in development hell until finally
it's it's getting made and one of the
good things about stories is if they're
timeless well one of my favorite
examples of which was no solace to its
author Mel Herman Melville is that Moby
Dick sold about 60 copies prior to
Melville's death
and within two decades after his death
it became not only an international
bestseller but the Great American Novel
so the stories are timeless and that's
what writers are capable of doing of
creating something timeless which is a
immense value obviously to the human
race the Iliad The Odyssey were composed
thousands of years ago and yet they're
still on every book stores shelves you
can find them all over the Internet
and so the power of stories I've always
loved the fact that they were story
grows up to be couldn't be a book or it
can strain story grew up and be a movie
I mean once said a screenplay
that I loved that won the Nichols award
one of the highest you know awards in
the business and it it was placed almost
at the top not quite at the top but I
read it loved it tried to sell it to the
studios they all thought it was too
original they didn't know who the author
was and they they end up passing so I
told the author let's turn this story
into a book and so long story short we
did and I sold it to a major publisher
and within a couple of weeks of selling
to a major publisher we had an option in
Hollywood and so led to a major studio
and it went into development and we've
done it kind of the opposite way as
somebody was starting to write a project
in one form and I told him to write it
in the other because of a random
conversation I had with a with an editor
and she thought it was sounded like the
best novel she'd ever heard and he
wasn't a novelist but long story short
within three months he wrote a novel and
we sold it and then sold it for 1.2
million dollars to you know a major
studio in Hollywood so I thought you
know that's my comparative literature
background that the idea of having two
different worlds to put together and
recognize how their you're related to
each other
I learned that there are wormholes
between New York and LA because when I
was just beginning to shop the the novel
in the second case
to New York I send it to only one
publisher which is the person that told
me it wasn't sound like a great idea she
didn't know I only sent it to her but I
sent it to her alone
and three days later I got a call from
George Clooney's partner asking if he
could option it and I said how did you
hear about that he said I can't tell you
and I said well you know if you can't
tell me do you want to read it I mean
what do you want to do any cause no no
we've read it already and we want to we
want to make an offer on it so that
began an auction for that property too
but I learned that there was a wormhole
going on because I called the editor and
fished around talking to her and she
denied that anyone had ever read it
outside of her office which is couldn't
have been true because clearly someone
had read it
he's got snuck out through the wormhole
so I thought I could only have done this
if I had the whole mentality that I will
not find my niche and only be working in
films I will not only work in books I
want to work in both I love them both
and they're just two different forms of
storytelling and why can't any story
that's dramatic end up in both camps and
that's kind of what I've done throughout
my career is tried to get a story for
both camps it's funny too because I
would think that the entrance into the
literary world the New York literary
world is much more based on you know
pedigree and different you know whereas
Hollywood and you've got a great script
anything goes you're in the front door
if they like it so it sounds like that's
not always the case that sounds like
that's my perception of it it's yeah I
mean that that's a you know without no
finding you it's an old-fashioned
perception okay it's kind of an
all-american old 50s 1950s before I was
born because you can have a great script
and get nowhere in Hollywood it's
getting it to the right person that
matters and even with the great script
as that one was where I talked to guy
into writing the book and then sold it
too you know and in option two he had a
great script and
and and he was able to get it to people
but they didn't buy it because they were
afraid because what's happened in the
last 20 years is that Hollywood and New
York have become corporatized they've
all been acquired by international
conglomerates you know there isn't a
single studio that isn't owned by some
foreign you know accumulation with the
exception of Disney which of course is
itself international conglomerate right
but Sony gilens Columbia and you know
paramount is owned by CBS Viacom you
know so because of that the executives
have totally changed from a world in
which and the same is true in publishing
from a world in which people with guts
and vision made decisions about doing
the story publishing it or
green-lighting a movie now it's it's
it's corporate people wearing suits who
are very worried for their jobs you know
whose I always say their main focus is
on their you know their their gold cards
and their new Mercedes and they don't
want to do anything to jeopardize that
whereas the heads of Studios in the old
days would just take chances this is a
great story I love it I'm gonna I'm
gonna do this story and but now they
can't they have to show marketing
reports and this is true in New York
just as well because fish yet has bought
you know the world warner books and CBS
owns Simon & Schuster and touchstone and
all those things every one of the big
companies hold Springs owns McMillan and
Thomas Dunne books and tour books and
st. Martin's Press and you know being
when Random House
Doubleday right they're all part of one
huge foreign conglomerate Bertelsmann
and so on so because of that everyone
has to think like corporate employees
they have to provide marketing pnls
you know to the editorial department in
the in the marketing department and the
marketing department has the last say
not the editorial department you know if
they go how do you know we're gonna sell
100,000 copies of this book
well I just have a gut feeling well
sorry your track record doesn't justify
your having to get feeling so they'll
let a really talented brilliant editor
make a couple of decisions like that a
year but if she doesn't prove it out by
those books becoming bestsellers you
know she gets less leash every year and
the same is true in Hollywood and the
studio's have gotten even worse because
they their focus now entirely on brands
and in the last six years or so they are
now doing a fraction of the number of
movies they used to do because they'd
rather spend two hundred million dollars
on a brand or then take a 50 million
dollar chance on a great story that has
no track record that's why Twilight got
kicked out of Paramount because it was
sitting there you know in development
hell for several years then paramount
didn't get it and they didn't understand
why it was gonna be great summit came
along and bought it from Paramount and
cashed out on it and paramount goes okay
well they didn't have any regrets
because there's no they there you know
no one sits around wringing hands that
they're all doing understandable logic
and no one lost their job over it that's
the important part whereas if you
greenlight a movie and it goes down the
tubes you could lose your job you know
then you're you're out shopping for a
new Mercedes you know you're leasing one
yeah yeah had another in place so that's
kind of what's happened to the world but
in the meantime this the need for
stories continues and storytellers are
still hugely in demand you just have to
find a new path each time that's how I
started you know the imprint so I can
get around that issue and now I just
take new to new york big brands like
something with the word kennedy on it or
the word dracula i can sell those still
but i don't i just i know i can't sell
smaller books i'll try sometimes because
i love the book so much but it variably
comes down to that are published this
ourselves
one of your mini books can is right time
right and so you say that the world can
be divided into two people productive
people and non productive people and
that you say productive people have a
love affair with time so I would love to
know what makes someone on the right
side of time whereas what's makes
someone sort of time is our enemy well
yeah that's a very good question and put
in a very intelligent way that makes it
hard to figure out the handle on it
because time is uh time is this it
doesn't really exist I mean time is a
human construct we we created time
squirrels and you know Chipmunks don't
have much idea of time you know the Sun
rises and the Sun Goes Down and they
know that rains but they don't think the
way we do we're you know they don't keep
track of their birthdays for example
like only humans do that and it's
unfortunate because it you know you're
only as old as you think you are that's
the way a squirrel looks at it and
nobody's arguing with the squirrel about
it you know but but humans know better
and people some people look at time as
the enemy and some people look at as a
friend there's an old Spanish saying
this is there's more time than life
which I always thought was a wonderful
way of looking at it because its net
sort of productive person would say
there is more time than life and another
Spanish or Italian saying says that life
is law is is short but wide and that's
another way that productive looking at
it like people say how could you do as
much stuff as you do well because that's
what I do I don't do anything else and I
used to give classes on time management
and do a lot of studies on it in fact
right time is filled with time
management theories and one of the
things I noticed about people is they
had no idea where their time went and
and they go I don't know where you get
find all the time and I would say like I
don't know where you lose it I mean we
all have the same amount of time and I
go how much time do we have by the way
how many hours are in a week and like
two out of ten people can answer that
question right off the top of their
heads because they've never really
multiplied 24 times seven and realized
exactly how many hours there are in a
week and so everyone has the same amount
of time so what I would do in a time
management class at UCLA or elsewhere as
I would say let's keep chart your time
this this week I just want you to make a
chart of what you do with your time and
let's come in and talk about it next
week when we come back together and they
come back in and went and that was
before I asked them how many hours were
in a week I would wait for the third
week to ask that question and they would
some people would come in with ninety
eight hour weeks and some people would
come in with sixty two hour weeks nobody
seemed to agree in general how many
hours there were in a week because the
hours they gave me didn't add up they
didn't make sense you know they'd say I
sleep like six hours a week but it
turned out in the third week of analysis
that there actually I mean six hours a
day it would turn out that actually they
were sleeping 10 hours a day they just
were telling themselves they slept six
hours a day how much time do you spend
talking on the telephone
so most people thought they spent maybe
15 minutes a day when in fact they might
it might be an hour every day but
they're spending on that and watching
television of course some people were
saying that they only spent maybe an
hour a day when they were released
spending three hours a day and but but a
productive person knows exactly how long
it takes to do something like when I
write a screenplay or a book I can tell
you how many hours it takes to to do it
and so I know that I can get it done in
a certain amount of time I mean Agatha
Christie apparently wrote as many as 10
books a year she had to use four or five
pen names because she just kept writing
when you think about it
writing is a function of how fast do you
type you know because if you have you're
always say in my writing book including
that one I always say if you don't if
you make it a rule not to sit down to
write
before you know what you're going to
write then you'll never waste any time
and you'll never have writer's block
so simply don't sit down until you know
what you're gonna write but then it's
just a matter of how fast can you type
so it's better to be walking along the
beach thinking about the structure of
your story then it is to be wasting a
lot of time sitting in front of computer
typing stuff and throwing it away and
all that stuff just figure it all out in
your head and we'll what if I forget it
well guess what if you forget it that's
probably good
you're forgetting forgettable things you
won't forget it when it starts getting
really good because then it'll do what
Faulkner said it'll start honk haunting
you and you won't be able to forget it
and then you'll just write it down
William Saroyan was asked once how long
it took him to write the human comedy
because somebody had told the journalist
that he took in with three days I love
drugstore and he said no I took me all
my life to write it I just took me three
days to type it out and and that's so if
you're productive you've already figured
out that there are certain things that
are completely unproductive such as
sitting in front of a blank screen
trying to figure out what to put down
next and other ways to do things that
make you productive and productive
people don't waste their time as I said
when it comes to waiting you don't wait
you just do something else you what I
call it rotate from one thing to another
so that you still have you have new
energy constantly all day cause you're
switching activities and when you switch
to a new activity you have new energy
just because of that but you're also
pulling energy from the previous
activity that's kind of pulling you back
and wanted you to do more on it but
that's good instead of listening to it
and going back and doing more on the
previous activity it's better to have
that kind of little anxiety going on
there because then the next time that
activity gets a chance at your time
it'll be ready and it'll be more
productive during that time compartment
so I think that's the whole difference
is between productive and unproductive
people have never figured out how to you
time they don't even know how to measure
time and they confuse they confuse
things I mean there are two functions in
life or two entities that we deal with
one is time and the other is work and
one of them is it is eternal and and
timeless and endless and the other one
is not and but people get it wrong the
one that's timeless and endless and
eternal is work not time unless you're
God you know but if you're not God then
guess what you have a limited amount of
time and the only problem is you don't
know what the limit is but that doesn't
matter because you just have to operate
anyway but what's infinite is work
because good work produces more work and
so does bad work right so no matter what
kind of work you're doing it keeps going
and you cannot manage it therefore
because it's a given that you can't
manage an infinite thing but you can
manage something that is finite and
that's time so managing time is what we
have to do and let's say if you're
writing a book and you know that you
type seven pages an hour at least then
you give yourself one hour every day to
write your book well at the end of a
hundred days you've got you know how
many pages 700 pages right so that's
it's not complicated to figure it out
but you have to manage the right thing
you're managing your time because the
work will happen only if you give it
time to attend it to it and what happens
to the people procrastinate because they
they think they're trying to manage the
work and they they don't know that you
can't manage to work like I'm going to
get this book done if it takes me all
summer and then nothing happens they
don't do it that isn't what you should
do you need to say I am going to work
from 7:00 to 8:00 every morning you know
without fail four five days a week it's
better than seven days a week because
your brain revolts when you make it stop
something that it's actually enjoying
so if you make it stop after the fifth
day
it's very upset and it spends the whole
weekend thinking about the project and
it's really raring to go on Monday when
you start again whereas if you keep it
going
it'll get worn out and it'll get bored
eventually because that's what brains do
so it that's so productive there's two
kinds of productive people to you know
the unproductive ones let's not talk
about I mean they have their own thing
going and I hope they're enjoying life
but productive people are divided into
two kinds and those are the happy ones
and the unhappy ones the unhappy ones
are the ones who've never figured out
the psychology of creativity and so
they're constantly surprised by it and
upset by it and that's why you have
Virginia Woolf and Hemingway and you
know Sylvia Plath offing themselves at
the end because they'd never figured it
out they've never figured out that at
the end of a project they're gonna get
depressed and they're going to go into
this postpartum depression that they may
never come out of but if if you're on
the other side of the thing the happy
productive person you figured that out
already so what do you do before you end
a project you start another project and
then you can't wait to get into the new
project so you don't mind finishing the
first project so you've eliminated
postpartum depression and that's simply
because you figured out how your
creative mind works which is what
writers time-it is all about and that's
what I mean by you know productive happy
productive versus unhappy productive
people you don't have to be miserable
and suicidal to be a writer you can be
perfectly happy by knowing your system
and not letting it do it to you this
might be an old wives tale as well or an
older version of this the unhappy writer
is having more depth in which to write
about and more and more in which to pull
from whereas the happy writers are just
scratching the surface and it might be
too much a movie of the week instead of
something that pulls at your sort of
emotional core and you put yourselves in
the the characters shoes I don't know
again is that does that de can we just
spell that then that you have to be
unhappy in that sense yeah you know this
is a famous dilemma that people have
been talking about for my whole lifetime
there was a book that came out years and
years ago called the drama of the to
trial Alice Miller yeah and thank you
for a very but but it's a very very
interesting book and it basically says
that writers should fear therapy because
it might Farrah pies you know take away
their their angst from which came all of
their you know their brilliant ideas and
it's just they're simply not true
because there's just too many examples
of productive writers who have plenty of
inks and one of my favorite examples of
Stephen King who published in my
magazine DreamWorks we sent out a letter
to artists all over the world including
him and said could you please tell us
whether dreams have any influence you
know on your creativity and if so give
us an example of a dream and in a
creative work that came from us for came
from it so Fellini sent us a cartoon
that he dreamed in the middle of the
night that led to eight and a half is
movie eight and a half and we got great
stuff from all kinds of people and
Stephen King finally up six months later
after everyone else sent us a very short
letter and he said this is my constant
nightmare I am sitting alone in attic
typing away and a little door on the
floor of the attic opens and a hideous
face comes out of the door and I start
typing as fast as I can because because
the faster I type the more the door
closes and if I slow down you know the
face keep coming out and he says does
that count and you know it's an example
of what you're talking about because he
has plenty of angst going on he has
plenty of terror
in fear and dark things in his some of
his most brilliant works like the
Shawshank Redemption and you know of The
Shining and he's not an unhappy writer
like he's he knows that he needs to put
the time in every day he's figured it
out and he's prolific and so on so
there's just too many examples of
balanced writers let's call the mentally
balanced writers one of my favorite
statements from the world of art is
Salvador Dali said one time the
difference between myself and a madman
is that I am not mad and I love that
because only an artist who knows how
close sanity is to insanity knows what
that means you know akise he's one of
those madmen who isn't mad whereas a lot
of other bad men are mad and you know
okay they kill themselves or they kill
somebody else or whatever so it's it's
all about knowing yourself I mean it's
all about figuring out how your mind
works improving it and testing it until
you know that before you know it you
look back and you go oh my god I've
written you know all these books that
all these things going on and I don't
think I'm crazy and on the other hand I
don't think I'm saying either you know
it's it's like you've just figured it
out and so you can doesn't mean you're
not having dark spells it's just that
you you kind of look at your dark spells
from the outside instead of from the
inside
you know they it's very common in
meditation and yoga to understand that
you can either be inside yourself all
the time and drive yourself crazy by
letting your mind run it you know what's
going on or you can like stay above your
mind and look down on all these thoughts
going by and all this stuff and
recognize that you the one looking is in
charge not all the thoughts and the
writers time has a whole theory about
how the creative mind works that way
where there's what I call the managing
editor looking at the the fight going on
inside your mind
and realizing that this can be
controlled if you trick the two sides of
the mind and force them to work together
that's kind of what it's all about to
become productive and happy at the same
time in it you know seems to work for a
lot of people can any book be made into
a movie any book any book no my I don't
think so like an instruction manual
that's been done though people have made
instructions else into movies but no not
any book but what makes the movie is is
absolute drama you have to have drama
and I'm not talking about a bad movie
I'm talking about a good movie a movie
of people will not you know fast-forward
through or switch channels on or
anything so to make a a worthy movie a
book has to have drama and that means it
has to have a very clear three acts
beginning middle and end and what
defines the beginning is is something
that hooks the audience into the story
so that it will not abandon the story
and an ending is something that makes
you leave the theater or turn off your
television very satisfied with the way
the story ended whether it's happy or
sad isn't the point but it's satisfying
like the end of witness where we realize
that the lovers cannot stay together
even though we want them to because it
just wouldn't make any sense and the way
the last shot is Peter we are taking a
long time to let the car drive down the
lane away from the farm onto the road
it's such a long shot that it gives you
a chance to go through your head and
think oh come on slow down turn around
make a u-turn or run after him and none
of that happens because your mind is now
going you know what that wouldn't make
any sense this is sad but it's got to
end but it still was beautiful and
that's good drama and good moviemaking
and the middle has got to be something
it's the hardest part for any writer
it's it's got to be something that keeps
you there
meaning filled with twists and turns and
reversals and unexpected events and so
on so that you don't want to turn out
and that's what if a book can do that
then it can be a movie and if a book
isn't doing that but has potential
because it has a strong protagonist and
a strong antagonist that's where a
treatment comes in you write a treatment
and and fix all the problems with the
book in the treatment and pitched the
treatment I've sold a number of movies
based on a treatment because the book
had problems and I almost wouldn't let
the buyers read the book because once
they said they want to do it I go okay
let's just go with the treatment please
but at the end if you know they're ready
to sign they have to look at the book
and then they'll say I see what you mean
but the treatment solves the problems
you know if the middles not dramatic
enough most especially a problem it
happens with novels is that the ending
is not powerful enough and clear enough
the third act is not clear enough in
many novels where you don't see that
there's a turning point that goes from
act 2 to act 3 because the editors in
New York are not as demanding as
audiences are in a movie theater they
don't really look for turning points the
same way an audience does and and
they're exceptions to all you know all
this stuff it's none of it as rules but
basically a three act structure needs to
be there and it has to be dramatic all
three acts have to be dramatic and you
have to have a protagonist that you're
gonna relate to you don't have to like
her or that you have to relate to her
and you have to have an antagonist who
is worthy of her and it's in every way
as strong as she is because otherwise
the ending is predictable and the
stronger the antagonist the stronger the
the protagonist and the stronger the
story is so I hope that answers the
question but books that have at least
some of those elements can be turned
into movies we actually
I used to have a class that is called
designing your novel to be a film
because the best place for that to
happen is on your original drawing board
make sure that when you design your
novel that you include these got these
things in the novel and that way you
won't be disappointed when nobody wants
to make it into a film why does the book
fail to become a movie if somebody wants
to adapt a book and they think they buy
the right whatever it is and just
somehow doesn't translate it doesn't
work out well there are hundreds of
reasons why that can happen but but they
come back in in categories that you get
used to
every book that's submitted to Hollywood
is what's called covered and in my
various webinars I talk about coverage
and coverage is a industry term for a
story report where a reader in the story
Department of a agency or of a
production company or a studio or in any
part of the business where stories go to
be covered and they're covered because
the executives who make the decisions
can't possibly read all the stories that
come in too many things are submitted
too many stories are submitted and in
the coverage it covers every single part
of the story from a one-line pitch of
the story to the genre of the story the
category the length of the story the
quality of the writing the dialogue the
characters supporting characters you
know main characters supporting
characters plot etc so you get a full
report in four or five pages that
analyzes the story and that ends with
recommendation pass consider with
development you know or accept with
development or just accept and and
accepts are extremely rare I mean
probably 1 to 2 percent or in that
category and the reason that most books
are turned down I've already mentioned
some of them but has to do with not
clear who the protagonist is
not strong enough antagonists too many
characters if you can't figure out
what's important what's not important
too much repetition the dialogue the
characters don't sound different from
each other they all sound the same and
we all know from literary you know
literature graduate school that one of
the common questions Inuit asked as
you're just given lines of dialogue from
plays and asked to identify the
character by one line of dialogue
because the great playwrights
make their dialogue characteristic to
each character and lady even get that
Macbeth would not be sounding like
Juliet you know there there always be
clear who's talking and and that's
another reason for a frequent turndowns
the audience isn't big enough you know a
story about Latvian Americans take in a
small neighborhood in Detroit you know
may get made as an indie movie if you
know somebody like Meryl Streep wants to
be in it because she's Latvian you know
but other than that the chances are that
Fox is not going to develop it because
they're looking at audience appeal you
know they're looking at demographics so
any of those reasons and all of those
reasons are are reasons why a book gets
turned down sometimes a book is to
internal and screenwriters struggle with
it but they can't figure out how to
externalize the constant thinking and
philosophizing of a character there are
examples of books that have done that
well like the world according to GARP
you know is an example but they're
usually internal stories are very hard
to turn into films and in what happens
is halfway through the attempt to do
that you realize you're inventing all
the dialogue and then how much that and
therefore how true is this movie to the
book at all you know is it even the same
book because if the book did everything
internally and you're inventing all the
dialogue you know what I mean it's so
there are a lot of reasons but they all
have to do with
with drama drama is about scenes and
scene is which is is a place and time in
which there is conflict two forces come
together in conflict and the conflict is
resolved and that scene is the unit of
drama and if the scenes in a book are
not clear enough scenes are very
distinguished in books and Vonnegut for
example his scenes can be two sentences
long in you know in Faulkner his scenes
can be 20 pages long and but but still
they'll be clear scenes my favorite
example of I think is shortest story in
American literature is goes like this
have you lived next door to a man who's
trying to play to learning to play the
viola that's what she asked the police
when she handed them the empty revolver
it's a it's a short story by a Richard
Brautigan and but there's a whole scene
write a whole story a whole scene told
in a couple of lines and just as the
tour de force to show that you don't
need a lot of words to make a scene we
get it right away and and that's drama
is a scene like that and there are two
kinds two components of drama as I
talked about in my various books I mean
one of them is action she hands them the
empty revolver and the other is dialogue
have you tried living next door to a
person learning to play the viola you
know that those are the two components
of action and drama dialogue and action
and dialogue like good morning how you
doing today is not dramatic and yet many
novels are filled with it with that kind
of dialogue so the great novelists that
have been made into great movies have
vital dialogue that is really action
dialogue like so line from Hemingway
that I love to quote and creative
writing classes these two people sitting
near a train station and at one point
she says to him would you please please
please please please please
stop talking and that's a great example
of a piece of dialogue that is pure
action you know that there's no hope for
their relationship after she says that
and and and it goes on to say the man
did not say anything for a moment then
he asked would you like a beer
and we know you know it's all over
between them but there's an example of
how great dialogue does you know like
from Chinatown you my mother my sister
my mother my sister my mother my sister
remember that she said tell the truth
and she keeps saying the same thing over
and over again until he finally realizes
that she's telling the truth
and that's when you have you know that
the writer knows what he's doing and
that's right it's why screenplay writing
is so much more difficult than novelists
because there are the harshest rules in
writing screenplays and in the harsh
rule really is only one harsh rule every
single word in the screenplays connected
to every other word and in a novel
that's just not true I mean you can't
you know the 600 page novel that just
can't be true and it isn't true but it
is true in the screenplay because if you
say a word and the audience you know
leaves the theater and they loved it
otherwise you know at the bar they're
gonna say but why did he say that one
thing to him like it made no sense you
know take care of yourself why do you
say that at the end of that scene and
they won't let go of that until they
figure it out and if they can't figure
it out thinking oh there's something
wrong with that story you know because
it's all you know like you can't focus a
camera on a red hat in a movie without
making that payoff later and and that's
just not true of novels for one thing
novels kind of float in in the air of
the reader you know as you read the book
you paint pictures in your head and
movies are much more demanding than that
because they have to make decisions what
does she look like and you you have to
cast her with the right color here and
you know one of the most famous lines in
history is from the Iliad
when everyone knows Helen of Troy is
supposed to be the most beautiful woman
who ever lived right
but homework is not going to deal with
that because that's just impossible so
what happens is it says when she
appeared he says the elders of Troy were
standing on the walls of Troy chattering
like locusts with each other until Helen
tell tell a hush fell among them as
Helen appeared and one of them says
terrible indeed is her likeness to that
of an immortal goddess and that is the
entire description of Helen of Troy
which you know can't be beat because it
leaves it completely to your imagination
what'd she look like and he wasn't about
to say she was no 5 foot 2 red hair blue
eyes etc which immediately will kill her
beauty and some people's minds and so
it's that's why drama is so much more
challenging
it's the ultimate expression of
storytelling and it's why movies are you
know hugely powerful instruments around
the world correct me if I'm wrong I'm
sorry was all the President's Men and
adaptation from Woodward Bernstein's
book okay yes the dialogue and that and
and and the the the running I just
remember in so many scenes that were
running and and can you talk about that
script in any way you know I'm not as
familiar with it story is I mean with
the script as I'd like to because I mean
I'd like to have recently read the book
and full script but one of the things
that you do in a story like that there's
the you you add the running because
there probably isn't a lot of running in
real life I mean these journalists are
probably too heavy to be running and
they don't look like Robert Redford
probably either yeah some other might
but they're not you know but but I think
that that's what the big challenge like
spotlight is an example like they took a
lot of a lot of reporting from Boston
Globe and turned it into a dramatic
movie that covered
you know collapsed many years into a few
years you have to take those liberties
and that's why you end up saying it's
fired by a true story instead of based
on a true story etc I've been through
that many times but adding action adding
drama is what you have to do right in
the scene in spotlight where Stanley
Tucci you don't see him yet you just
hear him yelling and his assistant and
so I think something's thrown and then
the look on Mark Ruffalo's face and then
that right there is enough to threaten
of set the stakes exactly and it's exact
it's it's good drama because it involves
the audience immediately because you
don't see what's happening so you see a
reaction to what's happening so you have
to figure out what's happening and one
of the common mistakes that you know
younger writers make is that they
patronize the audience by explaining too
much by thinking that every single thing
has to be you know there and when I
always say that when you're editing like
the top ten rules of editing are all the
same cut cut cut cut cut cut because
when you're in doubt about whether you
need something that alone is a reason
for cutting it just cut it you don't
need it the audience will make the jump
and will fill in the blanks and if you
don't let them fill in the blanks it's
called painting by the numbers then you
come across this patronizing to the
audience and they they get bored they
don't want to hear every detail you
don't have to say your honor in a court
scene every every single sentence you
don't have to say the character's name
every time you talk to the character I
mean these are people get get that out
of their system after ten years of
writing but at the beginning you don't
know where the lines are and the sense
of the audience I mean one of the things
I like to talk about is the psychology
of the audience like it's not the
psychology of the author that makes you
read a book you don't care about that
you know it's just like you're listening
to your friend talk about his latest
ballad in the hospital I mean how much
do you care about how he felt about
every day you know you pretend you care
as long as you can but he has any sense
at all he'll keep it keep it you know
cut it down right and truth is you don't
care about the psychology of the
characters either that's not what's
important what's important is your
psychology as
always the audience of psychology and
that's why a Hitchcock and Peter we're
really know what they're doing that that
drive away in witness is one of the most
brilliant parts of the film because of
the length of the driveway so it was a
location choice he's telling the
location manager I need a place that has
a long long long driveway that will give
me a 60-second tracking shot you know
and in the birds when the heroine takes
this flashlight without even testing
whether it works or not and starts
heading up the the wooden steps because
she hears rustling in the Attic
you know that is the longest walk up the
steps you've ever seen a film because it
is so stupid that the audience needs it
leads three or four steps to get it out
of their system saying oh come on why is
that every actress but why does she have
to have white underwear on anyway so
always at the end of a horror film and
why doesn't she test that you know so
once you get past that okay now she's on
the middle step and then you go through
like oh my god why is she you know this
doesn't make any sense oh I can't stand
this I don't want to watch this and then
a few more steps and by the time she
gets to the top step you're ready like
okay I paid to get scared this is it and
and that is using the psychology of the
audience that's the timing that the
audience needs to get into the exact
right mood you know it's just like the
speech and Julius Caesar where Marc
Anthony comes up after Brutus is
brilliant speech on the you know corpse
of of Caesar and Anthony comes up and
praises you know Brutus and speech and
calls him the Honorable Brutus and by
the end of his speech the kree's turned
the entire crowd against Brutus even
though they were all cheering for Brutus
at the beginning of his speech he takes
the psychology of the audience and
twists it around in a way that you know
you can see it coming but you don't care
you just want to go there with him and
it's not about anthony's nobody cares
about Antony's psychology you know and
nobody cares about Brutus and psychology
there that's not
important in nobody cares about
Shakespeare's psychology because nobody
knows what is chicken psychology is they
said you know the greatness of homer and
Shakespeare that they themselves were
nowhere to be found in their work their
characters were everywhere and the
characters speak directly to the
audience you know and that that's the
hardest thing about writing is figuring
that out
what are the biggest mistakes you see
new screenwriters make our first
screenplay I mean literally or
structurally dialogue character um
because the biggest mistakes they make
is usually their personalities but but
of the actual writer or yeah okay but
that aside I think the biggest mistake
is over explaining and not knowing how
to tunnel the background of the story
into the story instead of laying it out
like we just developed a brilliant
screenplay the last several years in
which the opening conversation just is
not convincing because there is no other
explanation for the words and the
conversation other than explaining to
the audience what's going on and and
that's a hard to avoid mistake because
you know you've got to explain what's
going on but if you do it overtly the
audience is gonna not believe the
dialogue they're not gonna believe you
know they're gonna not be able to
suspend their disbelief so you have to
sneak these things in to the story at
times when they're needed and not too
much too soon one of the common mistake
that the the root mistake beneath that
mistake is thinking that the audience is
not as smart as they are it's it's
looking down on your audience because
respecting the audience is essential to
good storytelling you have to believe in
the audience and you know imagine
sitting on this country porch and
telling the story with no audience right
I find that very hard to a man
because storytelling is about audiences
you you can immediately start telling
this story if even one person shows up
but sitting there and telling about
yourself
that isn't what a story is right so if
one person shows up and it's Jackie
you're gonna tell it differently then if
Sally showed up first and if Sally and
Jackie they're together you're gonna
tell it differently than you would have
to either one of them by themselves
that's just the nature of human
communication so not respecting the
audience or not realizing that it's all
about the audience it's probably the
biggest mistake and it takes a while to
get out of that mistake because the only
way to get out of it is through constant
feedback that tells you it's not
necessary because somebody told me once
like an editor is a person who tells a
writer when to stop writing and I
thought that was a actually a lot of
truth to that because how's the writer
gonna know unless somebody says you
don't need that and I think that that is
often the case with first green writers
as they they put a lot of things in they
don't need we need much less than then
you think we do we don't need a scene to
come to an you know to come to an end
it's okay to cut out of it I mean
writers are constantly have a great line
at the end of the same but then they add
a couple of more lines their insecurity
lines they call them so we instantly
just cross them out because they already
had a great line that's the end of the
same and yes everything hasn't been
quite wrapped up but that's that adds
energy when you cut that you're pouring
energy into the story when you leave it
there you're sucking energy out of the
story because the audience is like bored
through those last two lines and going
or do we need that I was I'm out of it
it you know you had me at a low kind of
you know and I think that's probably the
most common mistake is right over
writing just over writing you said
earlier personality just well
screenwriters have to be careful with
their personalities because by nature
they're very overtly at least self
you know aggressive people mostly that's
a mask for lack of self-confidence which
is a normal thing for a writer to have
we all have that no matter what stage
you reach you'll always have the lack of
self-confidence but then the world's
divided into those who do it anyway and
those who let that stop them from doing
it you know every actor has that before
he goes on stage some of the greatest
actors Richard Chamberlain used to throw
up before he went on stage and and but
he went on stage I mean it was just part
of what he did you know you get nervous
before you sorry and that's not a bad
thing that's a good thing you know if
you weren't nervous then you're not
doing something important so you know if
you're going into battle on the
battlefield or you should you be afraid
yes if you weren't afraid
HP you'd be nuts so I think that that's
what happens in personality is that
sometimes people are compensate in an
over aggressive way and it's an
automatic turnoff because one of the
several things about succeeding in
Hollywood is don't get on everyone's
life is too short list yeah I mean and
it's really true being that it's
sometimes you get on it immediately and
you'll never get off of it it's very
hard to break it and and you have to you
know realize that you you need to act
with the people in the business the way
you would act with true friends and who
will tell you you're an if
you're being an and Hollywood
won't they'll just say thank you so much
for coming well we'll be in touch with
you and you know that'll be the end of
it but I'll go
you know as soon as he's out of the room
and demanding it's part of demanding
because there's a kind of petulance that
sets in the longer a writer has worked
without you know reward and an
acclamation and compensation and it's
almost like I deserve this you're going
to give it to me now you know I had an
actress at dinner one night in the
middle of dinner she said you know a lot
of other people she said I demand
attention now and it was really funny
because the men thought
that was cute and the women did not they
did not but she was not reinvade 'add oh
no no the women definitely did not like
that petulance because you know men
thought it was sure-sure
cute because she was sexy and so on but
in today's world
Pecha especially Hollywood where the
stakes are so high everybody wants to
get in you know thousands of people are
lined up for every single position you
could ask for and they want people who
are cool and professional not hot-headed
and demanding and when I see a writer is
of the latter category I just kind of
run for the hills and I can n onac
writer is not that way when he's modest
and so on I will continue talking doing
for years even before I represent him or
work with him until I find something
that no I can work with because he's so
respectful and so you know not on I
choose to short list
you know he's that that's a very rare
thing but it's it's important when you
think about it any walk of life you know
you're not gonna the the uncle who you
can't stand to see it Thanksgiving is
not the one that you want to be
representing or making a movie with is
that I'm sorry to interrupt is that when
someone's to self-aggrandizing like it's
just this is the greatest thing and
there they won't take no for an answer
and it just comes yeah I mean that's
part of it because you don't tell us how
great it is just tell us the story get
out of the way you know of the story we
don't want to hear about we want to hear
this - your first pitch we don't want to
hear you know you haven't done this much
we want to hear that you practice this
and that you know exactly what to say we
want to see if you've got the goods and
that is the story like Mark Twain said
don't tell us the fat lady is going to
sing bring her out let her sing you know
that that's that's what we want to see
in other words don't draw attention to
yourself because that is not what we're
interested in we're interested in the
story and maybe we'll get interested in
you later like after you brought a
couple of good stories and then we go
way you know where you from and you know
what's your story but we don't want to
deal with it at the beginning because
the truth is no matter who you are if
your story is good we love you you know
we look because you told this story and
that's that's a great you know kind of
equalizer when you think about it it's a
real world of ideas but if you start
telling us about yourself and give us
the chance to hate you before where you
even started telling the story that ik
how stupid is that and I have to say
that years ago I rarely I stopped taking
writers to pitches of their stories
because they most of the time unsold the
story after they sold it for a very
simple reason they weren't looking at
the buyer they were in a coma they were
telling the story and they weren't
watching the buyers eyes which is all it
matters in a pitch like I can see
immediately if you're bored and I'm
gonna you know if I'm any value at all
I'll switch to another story to pitch
you you know because there's that's what
the the buyer is thinking can I do do I
like this story can I do something with
it
but sometimes you'll just hear one word
dragon and that'll be it click my eyes
go like let's see I've got a 350 and
then I've got a 330 like my brain is
thinking about other things because I
know I can't acquire a dragon story so
why am I wasting this person's time well
the person's not even listening and
looking at he so he goes on talking and
and but the other thing happens too he's
already said enough to sell you you're
totally this is what you're looking for
I can see it in your eyes but he keeps
talking so after a while now
the buyer is looking at him instead of
listening to the story he's looking at
him going why is this guy still talking
I love this I want to ask some questions
you know what I mean so that's an
example of a writer forgetting about the
most important part of his story which
is the audience his audience the reader
the audience is the most important part
of the story and when you forget it they
know the reader knows that you forgotten
them you
and then they're there to doubt they
closed the book can of the many books
that you've written yeah you have one in
you co-wrote entitled writing treatments
that sell and maybe you can hold it up
so up and see it it's a cool cover there
and first off do we define what is a
treatment well this is one of the things
that try and I looked into when we wrote
this book because we kept getting asked
that question by clients you know what
is the treatment we have to explain it
over and over again and it suddenly
occurred to us what is the treatment our
selves and what is their definition so
we did a survey of about 30 execs in
television and film and asked them that
question how would you define a
treatment and we asked them about ten
other questions and we really based the
book on their answers and basically the
answer is that a treatment is a
relatively brief written pitch of a
story intended to be dramatized as a
motion picture for film or television
and it's written in user friendly
grammar free quick language that is easy
to follow and it contains highlights the
most important characters and events the
obligatory scenes in the story that's
what a treatment is now so how long is
the treatment relatively brief three
pages to say 15 pages once it's passed
15 20 it's getting no longer relatively
brief and there was no industry
agreement on it and basically treatments
range from 5 to 10 pages good treatments
and we recommend that because of the
attention span of the who you're dealing
with the audience your reader the buyer
his attention span is limited and you do
not want to extend it because he won't
be there she won't be there at the end
of the story if you make it too long so
it's basically what a treatment is and
it's used for two purposes it diagnoses
the faults in a story so you write a
treatment of your story to see the
faults in it so it's a diagnostic tool
and then you fix them
and then it becomes the sales tool
because it people are willing to read a
treatment when they won't read a script
because the script is serious engagement
or as treatment can be read relatively
quickly and those are it's used in every
part of the industry and and it's
different from a synopsis because the
synopsis is a dry fully detailed summary
of a story you'd find a synopsis in a
coverage for example but the treatment
is a pitch
it's the substitute for a live pitch I
can't be doing a webinar called pitch
perfect which is about pitching and when
you get the rare occasion to do that but
now with the internet we're going to do
a virtual pitching so that people can
actually pitch to a producer and get an
answer and a pitch is extremely
fortunate chance to sell your story and
again you do not want to be preface it
with anything you don't want it reveal
your personality that's not what it's
about you want to just tell how strong
your story is by showing the story and a
treatment is the best you can do if you
don't have the opportunity to pitch life
so the treatment replaces a pitch and
it's what most people use and they use
it through email and through any other
method they have to hand a piece of
paper to someone else is there a chapter
to that you were surprised that people
commented on they had questions or even
from Amazon reviews was there is there a
point in the book where people are
there's it's just a topic of
conversation more so than others you
know I'd love to say that there is but
honestly we got in pretty strong
response positive response to the whole
book but I think the parts that that
caused people that make people the most
curious have to do with our analysis of
a movie of the week and that when we
first wrote the book there were a lot of
movies of the week in which we talked
about the seven act structure of a
television show and the 7x structure you
know there is a 3x structure
two stories all stories have a three-act
structure but in the Renaissance for
example stories had five acts and that's
because they divided the horrible act to
that everyone hates I call it the
Serengeti Plain because it's you know
it's the hardest part of the writing
they divided it into three acts and now
there's a five acts story and it's
easier to write because each act has
some beginning middle and end and each
act can be subdivided into twists and
turns and scenes so television duels
goes even further it makes it seven acts
and that's because of commercials that
have to come after each act etc so
people were curious to see that but when
they saw that that the executives at the
studios actually had a chart some of
them actually took the chart into a
pitch meeting and wrote down jotted down
what you know in the chart what the
writer with the pitch was saying about
what happens in each act and so on so
here's the filled out one I'm based on a
movie that we produced and it shows one
liners of the scenes that occur in each
act and I think people realized that
this was they didn't realize how
mechanical it was and honestly when I
hear that which I do often from writers
when I'm in the old dates at least when
I was teaching at university extensions
all over the country I realized that
they didn't have them in hella D to be
writers so it may be given a great
example
well mama named Millie Mayer god rest
her soul wonderful wonderful lady was a
client for years came up to me at a
Riverside
UC Riverside workshop after she goes I
didn't want to say anything in front of
the classic I didn't want people make
fun of me but I took my favorite book
The Grapes of Wrath and I outlined it
and is that stupid
and I said no you're the only craftsman
in the class I mean that's what a
carpenter would do if he wanted to make
a table he would take a table apart and
see how it was put together that's what
a mechanic would do if he wanted to
build an engine he'd take an engine
apart so that's exactly what you do and
when they see this kind
breakdown they understand you know
exactly how the mechanics of it work and
honestly until you get to that point
you're really not ready to be a
professional writer because if you
thought that writing was a magic you
know magic trick that you have to pull
off every time or a miracle which I
guess most writers probably would think
a miracle rather than magic trick then
it's impossible right but it's not
possible
I mean unassign impossible it's possible
to be a writer
people have been writers for centuries
they've been storytellers and
storytellers tell stories in parts and
they know what the parts are and they do
them in a way that makes sense and so
the sooner you get down to the mechanics
of how it works the better and that's
what we try to do in our books is to
show people the mechanics I'm looking
through for another there's another page
in here where we show what we call an
intensity chart where you kind of type
one-liners of your whole story on it on
a single piece of paper one-liners of
all the important scenes in the story
then you go between the lines and let's
say you put hyphens two hyphens for a
non dramatic scene or a scene with
relatively little drama and like five
hyphens for a scene with much more drama
and ten hyphens with maximum drama right
so now you've got a page that has all
these hyphens on it underneath the
sentences right then you draw a line
across the hyphens connecting the
hyphens and then you turn it on its side
you turn the piece of paper on its side
in which you've got is something that
looks like a rollercoaster and because
it shows you the ups and downs and your
stories based on the drama the intensity
of the drama in your stories and that is
a great diagnostic tool because if you
see that there's a whole slope that in
which the thing keeps going down down
down and doesn't go up for a while or it
levels off then you know you need to
work on that part of your story so
that's what I call the mechanical
approach you know what I mean by
mechanics like when you when you want it
outline the screen
or a book you just use three three by
five cards and you put on those three by
five cards the obligatory scenes in the
book and you won't fill up a whole card
because it'll just be a couple of words
on each card and what you understand
when you start doing that is that
creation of the literary work is what
araceli called an imitation of reality
it's not reality
you're not rebuilding the cider house
and the world around the cider house
you're faking it you're making the
reader believe it's there and you do
that mechanically by like I would if I
were making the movie I build a house
front that looks like the Souder cider
house right but it wouldn't have a back
because I'm only gonna shoot the front
of it so that's what you're doing when
you're writing your you're just doing
what's necessary to create the illusion
that you're trying to create and the
audience believes that the lusion is
real because it wants to believe that
and you've given them enough evidence to
make them believe it so you know when
you're watching one of the old movies
when they were just nobody was dealing
with production value the way we do now
you know it just takes a little bit to
make you believe in the story even if
the acting is bad right even if the set
is laughable but you still are in the
story if the story is good you know if
if the characters are good and the
dialogue is good and that's one of the
things that we try to instill in writers
has learned that I can't accept it
because it's easier than then you make
it you're not having to recreate a whole
world you're you need to do the right
strokes to make the painting look like a
person and that's what we try to do and
you know the treatment book when Millie
approached you after the course in
Riverside and said I'm so silly I did
this you saw something in her that if
the other writer said well I don't want
to take the grapes of wrath' and and
outline it well then they're kind of
they believe in this romance of being
able to write and just sort of sit down
and I'm gonna take a bottle of scotch
and a cigarette and pound away all the
things that happened to me
the image of being a writer you know
it's the romance from being a writer the
struggle the torment the agony and the
ecstasy all of those grandiose concepts
that writers have done to get bigger
payment paydays you know that's all good
like I had a writer it was a client four
years dear friend who make we sold like
12 of his screenplays and it took him
honestly
a week to write a screenplay Wow and it
took me three years to train him never
never to admit that in it and so where I
got him an agent and the agent was
always beating him up and saying you
can't say that you you have to you have
to say you need three months six months
or whatever you can't say you do it in a
week they won't you know we're trying to
get a million dollars for this you know
and that's the truth is you can do it in
a week but you can you know put it aside
for two months and then go back and work
on it some more and so on but because
the reality of writing is is much easier
than then the the myth of it and welker
Percy one of my favorite novelist I
wrote The Last Picture Show said perhaps
this the secret of speaking is having
something to say and that's that's what
it's all about you have a story to tell
then you can tell it's not a problem
just don't start writing it until you
know the story like you don't start
telling a joke before you know the joke
right you don't walk in with three by
five cards until a joke from a three by
five card you you know the thing by
heart and then you you tell it and it's
not the agony doesn't need to be the
agony and when you don't have a
structure as when you have learned the
mechanics of it like the productive two
kinds of productive writers when you
learn the mechanics you can be happy and
you can do it whenever you want to do it
like any writer who knows them will tell
you they can write on trains buses
planes they can write standing up
sitting down I had a dear friend Nancy
Friedman in my client for years who
wrote on her back for the last ten years
of her life because she couldn't
and she couldn't stand up and so she
running on her back and she just kept
writing books and you the writing is
easier if you know what you're doing and
you know whether it's Harlan Ellison or
Ray Bradbury they'll all tell you the
same thing but when you think it's this
huge agony and it is like Virginia Woolf
you know and so on
she's never figured it out that's why
she's believed that it has to be an
agony to to be good and I don't think
Shakespeare was an agony I think he was
just dashing the stuff off as fast as he
could right because he was reading
everything that was coming from Italy
and from you know south of Europe and
stealing it like crazy redoing it
copying it you heard stories all around
and he just couldn't wait you know
before going to the pub and after going
to the pub to sit down and - it off and
he revised you know he spent a lot of
time revising we know that from the
folios but it's it's not the it's not
the living in the garret starving thing
that has to happen at all it's just
figuring out what you're doing it's a
craft you know it's a craft that has to
be learned and the art comes in there
are brilliant people who do the craft
and there are not so brilliant people
who can do the craft so there's plenty
of room for art but it's not doesn't
have to be cutting your ear off kind of
thing can we go back for a moment for
the graph you were referring to and just
show the intensity on the side as you
mentioned yeah this this shows you what
you know this is what you're doing as
you do it you you're writing little
search sentences and you're putting
hyphens and then you're drawing a line
connecting them all but then when you
put it on the side you can see the shape
of your story and you can see where it
needs some attention you know where that
you know there is all these peaks here
but no real valleys so it would be much
more dramatic if you drop some of the
intensity or you added less intense
scenes in here so that the Rises would
be greater etc and you know it could be
that everything is just fine when you do
this and it looks really perfect but
most the time you'll discover that it's
a rollercoaster ride which is what you
want you know dear reader to go on you
want them to to be screaming all the
time basically and then toward the end
you see the highest peak and then it
levels down yeah levels down although
you know in today's storytelling world
maybe this is not the right way to end a
story you know it might be better to end
on a higher peak okay sorry no no this
is this is just a made-up story that we
use as an example here yeah so but you
should that mean that's just like my
client Millie Mayer outlined The Grapes
of Wrath you sit and sit down with a
movie like jaws or like the Meg that's
coming out in August from Warner
Brothers and and chart it and and you'll
see how conscious the story is of these
ups and downs I mean people that they
know what they're doing directors are
known for their ability to do that and
if you want you know you want a crazy
all-out screaming ride go see Lara Croft
or one of their James a lot of movies
and you'll you'll see that that's that's
what they tried to deliver to you and if
you want a more tempered ride where you
can get deeper into the story because
you have a moment to rest between Peaks
then you'll see another kind of story
sorry I cut you off but you were saying
that today's Peaks might end a little
higher would that be because of there's
a possibility of a sequel or yeah I mean
usually it's it's that and it's also
because we are - ever since the moment
that Star Wars hit the screens I'll
never forget that moment because when I
watched that movie I thought this is a
watershed in the history of movies we
will never look at movies the same way
again because the scenes were the
shortest scenes I've ever seen you know
the scenes before that probably averaged
two to three minutes but when in Star
Wars the seams seem like they lasted six
seconds or 10 seconds and you could not
see everything in the scene which made
you instantly fall in love with a movie
because you believed in the world if it
was so chock-full of stuff you couldn't
see it all you just have to go see it
again
and I thought this is brilliant and it
was a foreshadowing of the attention
span that we're now fully living with we
weren't quite there yet when it came out
it was a little ahead of its time but it
totally predicted the world we live in
now where our attention span is just
minut because we're being bombarded by
so many pieces of information from so
many directions we're distracted all the
time and you know the text is ringing
the phone is ringing that the email was
ringing you know our head is ringing our
eyes are buzzing from you know somebody
said Americans look in 52,000
commercials every day in a normal day
and I think that's true I mean if
assuming your commute to work and you're
looking at everything out there bus is
going by you know billboards etc so I
think that there's another example of a
filmmaker who understood the audience
psychology and who directly addressed it
who directly addressed that that's what
he's all about is grabbing your
psychology and playing with it
and you love it because nobody's done
that to you before nobody's nobody was
making movies that you had to
immediately go see again because you
wanted to see what that little gizmo
wasn't in the far corner that you didn't
happen to focus on and now the scenes
over and you're all out to another scene
and you missed that so you got to go
back and train your eye to watch for
that corner and you know how that is you
you're always thinking next time I want
you I'm gonna really watch this corner
or something this corner because I know
I don't have a chance to see it all and
that is really screwing with the
psychology of the audience love that yet
another book of yours is sell your story
to Hollywood the writers pocket guide
that the business of show business I
know there's lots of great nuggets in
there something I saw from the Amazon
page there are four things in order that
I'm about to read that will guarantee
success I think and this is in the
foreword or something perseverance and
this is in this order or determination
or stamina
connection be fun to work with and
lastly talent really that's the order
yeah that's definitely the order I mean
actually I mean I've in my mind I've
added another one before Talent which is
luck okay luck is definitely important
but yeah you can think about it some
movies get made just because of
perseverance somebody keeps persevering
and though they can get the movie made
and somebody can make a movie because
they have connections you know Sophia
Coppola you know she got to make a movie
she's got incredible connections and
many other people in Hollywood
and being fun to work with that happens
all the time movies get made because of
that but I've never really seen a movie
get made just because of talent so of
all these things the three that that I
started with like perseverance etcetera
being fun to work with these are
sufficient causes of movies in other
words all you need is one of those and
you're able to make a movie but telling
is not sufficient you have to have
talent plus one of those other things to
make a movie and there's plenty of
talent around the good news I mean
that's so that's the bad news talent is
not enough to make a movie but the good
news is that if you have talent
it's what el everybody's looking for in
Hollywood looking for somebody who's
truly talent because they don't want
movies that are just made with
perseverance or being fun to work with
or having connections they want truly
good movies so if you've got talent
that's great but you need to get those
other things you need to persevere it's
not a you know a career for the
faint-hearted you know if you say I'm
going to give myself five years and then
I'm gonna go back to my horse ranch and
Utah you'll be back there before you
know it because life loves little deals
like that and you'll always get you back
to the horse ranch if you say that it'll
be no limit on my career I'm going to
continue no matter what then you've got
a chance to do it and maybe you'll get
lucky along the way but I always say
build the tracks for success don't build
them based on luck so yeah that's
luck is an important part of it because
sometimes you can have everything ready
to go and somebody comes out with a
similar movie and you can't do it going
back to the school of thought of two
types of people unproductive
negative versus positive what about
unhonest talent versus harness talent
and I'm making my little genre here but
people that there's so much talent here
but there's a lot of people that don't
harness it and they spin the reels
talking about these ideas how does
someone go into the harnessed category
well it going to the hardest category
just means discipline to sit down and
actually figure out time and use the
time and just you know determined to do
it you have to be determined you have to
persevere there are a lot of people that
have what I call artistic syndrome who
would like to be creative who say
they're creative who shy who show some
signs of creativity but creativity is
actually having finished a script you
know having finished a novel and
continuing to write another one while
you're waiting for the reaction on the
first one creativity is like I can't
stop writing this I keep getting stories
and I keep can't wait to get to the next
one so you don't really wait at all when
you send it out you you just now I can
do the next one you keep writing and
that's somebody who's harnessing their
talent unhonest means when you've
booby-trapped your talent by either not
sitting down being a fear of failure or
whatever your reasons are
procrastination
you know Tony Robbins always says the
best way to deal with procrastination
correct procrastination is to just
postpone it oh yeah you can do that
later but right now get to work so
harness talent is all a matter of
discipline and determination you know
starts with determination turns it into
discipline discipline turns into work
work is based on time allotted to it as
the ancient philosopher he's the odd
said if you put a little upon a little
soon it will become a lot that's it you
do five pages a day
that's 60 pages you know after 12 days
right so it's it's just inevitable it's
the law of accumulating capital and if
people aren't doing that then they're
they're completely out of hardest and
the only person who can really harness
the writer is himself so you can't
nobody can harness for you you can get a
manager to help you with that you can
get a disciplinarian to help you with it
but at the end of the day there are more
ways to evade discipline than there are
to impose it that's the genius of
humanity right
lastly you said something about being
called back to the horse ranch giving
yourself five years someone just
commented on our Channel the other day
and they had a very valid point about
give yourself three years they were
referring to acting and I agreed with a
lot of their their statements but they
said they gave up this acting pursuit
and they should have done it sooner and
now they have a corporate job and things
are much better for them should someone
really put this like I mean my argument
was well what if they know they're never
gonna be sort of this corporate type I
mean it takes a certain type to sit
behind a desk or attend meetings and
pretend like you really want to be there
some people aren't cut out for that and
what if you know that about yourself
should you really give yourself this
time limit what if you know that you're
not cut out for the corporate world yeah
their point was give yourself three
years max to come to LA whatever become
an actor you could insert writing that's
that's like saying give yourself a year
to go to Europe and get your wild oats
out of your system before you settle
down and get engaged or something you
know if that's the way you're looking at
it then it will just be a three year
lark you know it's not a career
commitment you know there's a great
great moment in a movie called burlesque
I don't know if you saw that movie but
it's Christina Aguilera isn't it and
then one of the opening scenes in her
little town she goes to the bus station
and she stands in front of the ticket
window and she says I mean I wanted to
get to a light and he looks at her and
goes one-way or roundtrip and
you gotta be kidding me and as
its it's lying in the movie that defines
career commitment you know she's not
going to go to LA and come back she's
going to LA period that's the end of the
story and that's why movies like that in
la-la land you know put artists in tears
because they're true true examples of
true stories about what artists go
through when they make decisions to give
up things and you know I used to give a
class and you see like all keeping your
spirits up for creative people and one
day I was going around the circle the
first day of class and having people
introduce themselves they were mostly
actors and actresses who signed up for
it for obvious reasons and the first one
I said please give us your name so we'll
remember your name and where you're from
or you know give us your name and where
you're from and what is to tell us what
is the question that you hate to hear
most you know and a party in LA and so
the first woman says my name is Carol
and I'm from Detroit and the question I
hate to hear the most is when are you
gonna go back to Detroit and work for
the post office and I said and how do
you react to that she goes usually by
bursting into tears and running out of
the room I go oh okay so we're gonna
work on that in this class so I asked
for next class next person my name is
Ellis I'm from Southern California and
the question I hate to hear the most at
parties is what have you been in big
lately that I've seen and I said it how
do you react to that she goes I say the
Pacific Ocean so there's an example of a
harnessed person and a nun harness
person right the hardest person knows
that she's gonna get stupid questions
from stupid people insensitive people
who aren't really thinking and that
there's nothing in the world that's
gonna stop that from happening so she's
gonna protect yourself by coming up with
an answer
beforehand so she doesn't have to
running out of the room and cry and the
other person is unhonest cuz she goes
out of the room in Christ she's the one
that believes this artistry thing is
some magic you know miracle that has to
happen and she doesn't understand it's
mechanical you know first thing you have
to do is protect your biggest asset
which is your brain and if you haven't
figured out how to do that then don't go
out in public yet because people are not
gonna stop start suddenly being
sensitive the moment you appear in
public they've never shown any sign of
it in the human history right I always
loved this book I read ago years ago as
a graduate student call it began in
Babel the history of the world you know
told with a sense of humor and m'p at
half of the book at the beginning is
when you really think about it people on
the whole are extremely stupid and it's
a carving on the walls of Nineveh 3200
BC and it's kind of comforting to read
that because you go well nothing's
changed you know we're still there we're
still stupid and you know that's part of
the human comedy but don't be stupid if
it's your you know your whole career at
stake you're the one has to build the
you know use the tools to build a
defense around yourself so you can
continue your career and people are not
going to help you until they see that
you've got that figured out then they'll
help you you know just the way they are
that goes back to what you said about
the sort of crackpot neighbor and the
garage making these paintings and then
everyone thinks they're crazy until they
sell one for a million or two and then
all of a sudden everyone wants to know
him so yeah everyone thinks you're a
genius and and and predicts and said I
always knew you would do well like my
father told me I was an idiot when I
became a professor like he didn't
understand how I was gonna make a living
because I didn't sign up for pre-med I
signed up for classics in college and 19
years later when I told him I was
leaving being a professor for you know
being a producer he told me how it's
crazy that how is I gonna make a living
and in 4 weeks later he was on the set
of one of my movies and said this is
great keep do
Nestle and host so if you put a lot of
truck on what other people think you'll
be a mess all your life I mean one of
the things I really hate to see is
someone who is all about just pleasing
people and will say whatever they need
to say to please the people in front of
them and then you know you realize they
don't have a mind of their own and
that's that's too bad too bad to lose
your life to spend your life without a
mind of your own
it's a terrible a mind is a terrible
thing to lose as they say and the writer
is somebody I think who's exploited
their mind to the to the max and and
take it you know followed its lead into
places that it would never have imagined
they would go and I think that's heroic
you know right way of life and and the
world needs more storytellers